on va rejoindre tout de suite jean
pierre colomb et s le porte parole de
l'association de police union des
policiers nationaux indépendants une
attaque comme celle ci n'a pas besoin
d'appartenir à un réseau un structure et
c'est ce que vous nous expliquer tout à
l'heure je le maintiens dès lors qu'on a
sur notre territoire des gens qui sont
convaincus que ce qu'ils font est guidée
par la main de dieu et qui ne seront
même récompensés dans une autre vie des
actes qui pourront comme être sûrs
durant leur vie terrestre
on peut imaginer que potentiellement on
a des centaines d'individus capables de
passer à l'acte sans nécessairement
recevoir de soutien logistique et une
situés à l'étranger ou de soutien
logistique structuré et maintenant d'une
organisation mais je dirais qu'on
comparable à ce qu'on a connu dans les
années passées en plus on les confronte
et on peut très bien être confronté
pardon à des actes spontanés autonome
d'individus qui ont je dirais la foi
chevillée au corps et qui ont assez de
motivation pour le faire justement ces
attaques spontanée comme celle que l'on
vient de connaître aujourd'hui on
imagine que ce sont des attaques plus
compliquées à prévoir pour les forces de
l'ordre a détourné oui à moins à moins
d'avoir une information d'autres
destinataires d'une information précise
par dénonciation ou autres moyens
il est quasi impossible de l'anticiper
c'est mon pas qui des questions
difficiles pas il est quasiment
impossible d'anticiper une action contre
comme je disais qui est ce qui serait
spontané il qui que serait consécutive
un élément déclenchant une réflexion on
est en plein procès charlie hebdo on
peut imaginer que des individus hommes
ou femmes soient plus réceptive à ce qui
est en train de se passer et considèrent
comme de leurs missions de leur devoir
de passer à l'acte de passer à un acte
terroriste que nous qualifions happy
rock terroriste ce qui pour eux est un
acte de foi alors une enquête a été
ouverte par le parquet antiterroriste
qu'est ce que l'on peut attendre
aujourd'hui 2
cette enquête est ce qu'on pouvait
attendre c'est ce que je convient
d'évoquer de savoir si on a affaire à
des individus qui ferait partie d'un
groupe qui gère l'argent puisé tendue et
ce qu'ils appartiendraient savoir s'ils
appartiennent à virer ce qui est
quelconque ou un groupe de réflexion
quelqu'un de savoir s'ils ont
effectivement pourquoi pas adhérer les
liens à l'étranger pendant voilà toutes
sortes de choses là c'est beaucoup trop
tout pour apporter une à avoir une
réflexion constructive sur le sujet mais
l'anc est oui nous en dira plus sur
dalle le profil de ces individus a
priori serait 2 donc bon on en saura
plus ce sont les membres d'une même
famille juste des amis ou est ce que ce
sont des ennemis qui soit rencontrer
dans un même lieu de culte sa seule
enquête pourra le déterminer
on sait que des organisations
terroristes avaient menacé la france ces
dernières semaines est ce que cette
attaque vous surprend vous étonne non
pas du tout moi ça me surprend
absolument pas c'était même c'était même
prévisible une certaine manière nous
sommes en permanence confrontés à cette
difficulté d'accepter ou pas je dirais
l'ironie ou la dérision est le message
qui peut être considéré comme anti
clérical une manière très large lui
reste donc à partir du moment où on est
dans un contexte de deux procès hyper
médiatisé
donc une forme de je dirais devoir de
mémoire par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
au préjudice de charlie hebdo par
rapport aux appels de l'étranger aux
groupuscules radicaux islamistes
à l'étranger c'est pas du tout
surprenant que des individus passent à
passer à l'action et j'ai presque envie
de dire qu'il est on peut craindre qu'il
y ait acquis dans les d'autres ce que
aussi par les autres d'autres potentiels
attaqué ce que la première crainte des
forces de but de police au moment où on
lui ces attaques c'est qu'il n'y en ait
d'autres
au même moment dans d'autres endroits et
bien sûr oui c'est le scénario le
scénario le pire scénario qu'on puisse
envisager c'est la démultiplication d
art d actes d actes terroristes comme on
en a eu 13 novembre
on n'est peut-être pas dans cette
configuration faut pas non plus on y
défendre une perte de stress assez assez
tendue c'est peut-être le moment de
rajouter on peut pas le savoir
aujourd'hui alors on parle peut-être que
d'autres services ont des informations
plus précises dans mon niveau je n'étais
pas bon maintenant le scénario de sur
actes ou de l'acte complémentaires ou
supplémentaire et pas du tout du rgi du
fantasme et on peut imaginer que ben oui
d'autres individus nés leur conscience
réveillé par celui là même on l'a vu
tout à l'heure
le deuxième suspect a été arrêté est
l'un des premiers le premier suspect a
été arrêté il ya un peu plus d'une heure
maintenant du côté de la place de la
bastille finalement arrestation a plutôt
rapide oui et c'est tant mieux
c'est tant mieux mais c'est pas tout à
fait surprenant non plus on peut
imaginer que la volonté des individus et
était de marquer marquer l'instant par
rapport aux et on en revient encore au
procès il n'y a peut-être pas de volonté
nécessairement de réitérer ce qui s'est
passé le 13 novembre si ces cas tant
mieux on va pas se plaindre qui ait pas
plus de victimes que ça et d'ailleurs
faut avoir une pensée pour ces victimes
innocentes qui ont pris des ddd coup de
dés coups de carte blanche aux et qui
pour certains dont certains la vie est
en suspens donc faut pas qu'on pas
l'oublier donc
voilà quoi qu'est-ce que ça va sur quoi
cela va déboucher ce qui va y avoir une
sur actions une démultiplication des
axes on peut pas on peut pas s'empêcher
d'y penser on peut pas s'empêcher de
l'imaginer on voit à quel point la
sensibilité est à cran et des vocations
de passer à l'acte peuvent se manifester
alors on va entendre un dans quelques
instants dans quelques minutes ce même
le premier ministre en compagnie de
gerdemann à son ministre de l'intérieur
est ce qu'on peut imaginer un niveau d'
alerte qui va s'élever des d aujourd'hui
dès demain on peut tout imaginer non de
toute façon il est évident que dans le
contexte
dans ce contexte la poste acte
terrorisme et contexte de procès qui va
durer d'ailleurs qui pak est loin d'être
terminée il faut renforcer la vigilance
au maximum au maximum mais là encore je
voudrais insister sur un point qui est
quand même essentiel on
on sait depuis longtemps depuis quelques
années maintenant comment que de relais
sur le terrain pour détecter ce type de
personnalité il ya un déficit de
remontée d'informations de détection de
ces individus qu'on compagnie au
centuple puisqu'on a plus de police de
proximité qu'on a plus de réseau de
proximité et services de renseignement
sont quand même assez décalée du terrain
pour des raisons objectives c'est tout
simplement dans beaucoup de quartiers
vous tenez le secteur de votre
territoire national il n'y a plus de
police de proximité
donc si ces individualités citant
tébessa encore l' enquête le dira on
verra si c'est si ce que j ai vérifié ou
pas dont je parlais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de réserve mais on verra s'ils
avaient eu moyens éventuellement de
détecter leur présence et leur activisme
grâce à un réseau de police puis danse
au niveau du terrain vous le disiez
manque de moyens c'est le manque de
moyens financiers manquent de moyens
humain et est ce que les politiques sont
sont d'accord et garçon conscient de ce
manque dans les rangs de la police
écoutez nous en tout cas au niveau un
temps passé au niveau d'organisations
syndicales ou la vie au travers de cette
association pour laquelle je supporte
parole on n'a de cesse que de le rayer
on n'a eu de cesse que de dénoncer ce
déficit de présence sur le terrain
déficit de moyens qu'il soit matériel ou
humain au niveau de ce qu'on appelle
vraiment la police dite de proximité qui
est des recettes terme qui compliquait
employés parce que certains il y accorde
une importance politique qui devrait pas
quand on parle de police de proximité
s'agisse tout simplement d'avoir un lien
police citoyenneté au quotidien et c'est
de ça dont nous souffrons aujourd'hui
c'est que le politique a résonné à ce
niveau là en termes budgétaires
uniquement budgétaire de la même façon
qu'il a résonné vis-à-vis des services
de santé et qu'il a retirés du terrain
bon nombre de policiers qui jouait le
rôle de renseignement il y avait ce rôle
de renseignement qu'avec son rôle de
contact avec les associations de
quartiers avec la citoyenneté tout
simplement et qui faisait que
mécaniquement naturellement tous les
renseignements remontée qui est des
signaux d alerte était était été relayée
aujourd'hui on a plus ça on est
toutefois clair on a plus ça parce que
tout simplement on a résonné avec une
règle à calcul et des tableaux excel et
que la présence policière dans certains
secteurs et fameux quartier secteur
perdus de la république il n'y a plus de
remontées d'informations maintenant
attention je m'excuse ce que je viens de
dire deux ans et demi vraiment entre
entre parenthèses a publié par rapport à
l'acte qu'il a d'être commis alors en ce
moment sera plus quand on sera éclairé
sur la personnalité de ces deux de ces
deux activistes et justement jean pierre
combien ce genre d'événement la
recrudescence de ce genre d'événement
est ce que ça peut être des éléments
déclencheurs justement pour pour les
politiques afin qu'ils puissent répondre
à vos demandes de moyens financiers et
humains
si c'était le cas il ya longtemps que
c'est une problématique serait prise en
compte sérieusement ne sont pas non j'ai
l'impression que non j'ai l'impression
qu'il a pas du tout de réaction globale
on raisonne en termes de communication
spontanée sporadiques ponctuelle on est
dans la communication politique
politicienne mais de réformes globales
sur le devenir d'une police de quartier
de secteurs et de remonter l'information
existe à l exil existe mais au travers
du prisme du prisme budgétaires et
financiers uniquement malheureusement
vous savez on est relié à la croisée des
chemins où le des courants de pensée on
renoncer purement et simplement à ce
qu'on connaît depuis très très longtemps
depuis 50 ans c'est à dire le service
public et ce service public
on oublie qu'il se traduit par et bien
tout simplement le lien citoyen autres
la police et la citoyenneté
dès lors qu'on renonce à sa c'est la
porte ouverte à tous et donc de fait à
la désertification de certains secteurs
ont de vraies anticipations policière on
devrait entendre dans quelques instants
le premier ministre jean castex en
compagnie de son ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin plusieurs journalistes
se sont déjà mis en place donc cette
intervention doit être imminente matin
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
sortie du premier ministre et du
ministre de l'intérieur
il en sortira pas grand chose il en
sortira certainement une carriè
affirmations de volonté du gouvernement
enfin bon c'est un laïus qu'on connait
je pense qu'ils pourraient dire d'autre
du reste à il va pas il va il va pas
dire qu'il va il peut pas tenir un autre
discours que celui de la fermeté par
rapport à ce qui vient de se passer je
peux vous le faire le discours par
avance en nous disant que tous les
moyens seront mis en oeuvre pour arrêter
d'éventuels complices il y en a pour que
ces actes ne se réitère pas et voilà on
connaît la suite
ça fait très longtemps qu'on entend ce
genre de discours on les a entendus
après mes rares est entendue après
charlie hebdo les entrevues après le 13
novembre mais mais fondamentalement nous
savons tous tous ceux qui sont un petit
peu informés savons tous que de toute
façon on ne peut pas anticiper ce type
de d'actes et que surtout il y à un
terreau favorable à ce que ça se
reproduise et que ça se démultiplie
vous savez la parade la parade politique
est là elle a une limite celle de la
réalité et de du concret merci jean
pierre colombiès d'avoir été avec nous
sur les antennes d'ayrté france rester
avec nous on viendra bien entendu vers
vous lors de cette journée